calling all superheroes the awesome
animated series DC superhero girls is
back with a reboot and it's better than
ever these girls may be superheroes but
they are also super relatable get it
here's what you need to know about the
new DC superhero girls the original DC
superhero girls ran for an amazing five
seasons it followed the story of a group
of girls from superhero High School in
Metropolis the main character was
Batgirl she moved to Metropolis from
Gotham she befriended Diana Prince
aka Wonder Woman her squad also included
Supergirl Harley Quinn poison ivy katana
Green Lantern and bumblebee together
they navigated life as teenagers while
also learning how to harness their
powers they were an unstoppable duo the
original series ended in 2018 but then
we found out about a brand new one it
was originally slated to appear on
Cartoon Network there aren't a lot of
details yet but they have released some
info about the main characters some of
the fan favorites are gone in the new
series at least as regular characters
Harley Quinn and poison ivy are no
longer BFFs with that girl we have also
said goodbye to katana but don't worry
Wonder Woman is still the ringleader and
Supergirl and bumblebee haven't gone
anywhere
Batgirl also has a new friend in the
show we'll tell you more about Zatanna
later this new series is created by
Lauren Faust she is the genius behind My
Little Pony she also created Foster's
Home for Imaginary Friends and wrote for
Powerpuff Girls so we know that this new
DC superhero girl show will be epic
Lauren Faust is amazing high school can
be a really tough time but also a lot of
fun it gets way more complicated if you
have superpowers and a secret identity
then there is a whole job of protecting
metropolis from teenage supervillains
yikes that's a lot even though these
girls are superheroes they are also
really relatable let's take a look
Batgirl the star of the show is Barbara
Gordon she is the daughter of
Commissioner Gordon from the Gotham
police department they moved to
Metropolis
which makes Barbara or Babs the new girl
in town she was not looking forward to
moving to a new high school we get it
it's hard to fit in a brain
new school luckily Babs meets her crew
she finds friends who accept her for who
she is that is so important in this new
version Babs is goofy and outgoing and
she can be a little awkward especially
when it comes to Batman
she is a total fangirl for him she
freaks out about anything to do with
Batman we can relate some celebrities
just make us go crazy who do you go
total fangirl for let us know in the
comments Babs is more than just a
superfan she is crazy smart in the
original series she got into superhero
high school just because of her brains
she is an inventor she makes all sorts
of gadgets but she's not perfect
she makes lots of mistakes and her
inventions she doesn't sweat it though
even the smartest kids struggle with
stuff sometimes
spats works at the burrito bucket which
isn't a great job sometimes first jobs
are the worst in the original series
Batgirl had a tough dog named ace we
don't know if she has a dog in the new
show but she does get to care for the
class pet it's a hamster
how cute she's a tomboy she rocks a
purple hoodie with that ears and stripes
knee-high socks
she loves sweets her favorite spot to
hang out is sweet justice a pastry shop
YUM that girl takes her role as a
superhero very seriously but she totally
depends on her squad we are so excited
to see this new version of Batgirl in
action she is going to be awesome Wonder
Woman the fearless leader of the Super
Hero Squad is none other than of Wonder
Woman her civilian name is Diana Prince
and she is a princess of the Amazons but
don't let that title fool you she's not
some dainty little princess she is one
tough girl
she has super strength which comes in
really handy when she is fighting crime
she is a star athlete at superhero high
- but she isn't a dumb jock she is very
smart she makes the best grades in all
her classes she can fly and she has all
her superhero gadgets of course her arm
braces are invincible and let's not
forget the lasso of truth she has
amazing superpowers
she also isn't completely human she was
created by Zeus out of clay so what and
you thought you had a weird family
Diana grew up on gay mascara the secret
location were all the Amazons lived so
she is a little clueless when it comes
to normal teenager stuff she talks very
formally and things like texting are
really hard for her emojis make no sense
she messes up English phrases sometimes
which is hilarious for instance she
tells her team to Swit themselves
instead of split up ourselves split up
she relies on her friends to help her
adapt to teenager life poor Diana she
doesn't try to be goofy but sometimes
she just can't help it there wasn't a
lot of normal stuff on Themis Keira like
pizza and cellphones but she is smart
and learns quick that's good because
there's a lot to know about being a teen
but she is really kind and friendly she
is a super loyal friend and believes in
the power of sisterhood she is an
awesome leader of the DC superhero girls
we are excited to see a lot more of this
new Wonder Woman Supergirl
we are so excited that Supergirl is
returning for the new series she was an
awesome bestie to Batgirl we don't know
a whole lot about the new version yet
but we do know that they are playing up
her super strength just check out those
muscles super girls real name is Cara
zor-el she is the cousin of Superman
aka Clark Kent that means that she is
also an alien from planet Krypton she
has a ton of superpowers she can fly
obviously she has x-ray and heat vision
she's really fast and crazy strong she
also has ice breath is that like morning
breath maybe a mental health and the
original Supergirl was really friendly
she was also very clumsy the new Cara is
tough she doesn't smile much and she's
always ready to fight she thinks
fighting crime is a blast she also has a
really bad habit she sleep flies thus
she goes out flying in her sleep there's
a hilarious super-short where Babs has
to get her back to bed at a sleepover
based on this short it looks like she is
probably still that girl's bestie we are
excited to see how their new
personalities get along the new
Supergirl is more of a tomboy than the
old one she has shorter blonde hair and
huge biceps but she isn't invincible
just like Superman
Supergirl can be defeated by kryptonite
those are colorful rocks from her home
planet they come in several colors and
they all weaken her the green ones are
fatal we are loving this new
interpretation of Supergirl we wonder if
she is still as clumsy as she was before
bumblebee bumblebee was always one of
our favorite characters
we are glad she is back in the new DC
superhero girls
bumblebees real name is Karen Beecher
Duncan we know she is back in the show
but we don't know how much she has
changed we do know that she is almost
always tiny in her superhero form
bumblebee has some really cool powers
she has a really tough exoskeleton like
a bug she can fly and her shrinking
comes in handy she also has enhanced
strength and speed in the original show
Karen was a total social butterfly she
was friendly and outgoing and she loves
to gossip she always knew exactly what
was going on her ability to shrink into
a tiny bug made her a great spy she
could always find out what the
supervillains were plating she would
relay the message back to her squad so
they were never surprised by evil plans
bumblebee is really stylish and those
arm bracelets she wears can emit a sonic
blast pretty cool so far we haven't seen
much from bumblebee but she is there
when they fight mr. freeze she appears
to be shy and unable to stand up for
herself when she is in her human form
we cannot wait to see what changes were
made to her character Green Lantern the
last returning character is Green
Lantern and we love DC superhero girls
for making the Green Lantern a girl it's
perfect
the Green Lantern can be anyone who has
the alien ring on the series her real
name is Jessica Cruz Jessica wears a
cool green outfit do you think she likes
a green before she was the Green Lantern
Jessica is a very opinionated girl she's
not afraid to tell people when they are
wrong and she stands up for her friends
Karen she cares a lot about the
environment it makes sense because she
is supposed to be protecting her threats
to earth don't always look like
supervillains you know Jessica's also
against violence yep you heard us right
she is a superhero who doesn't use
violence she tries to find other ways to
win we wonder if that causes a lot of
issues with her fellow superhero girls
they aren't afraid to fight
but Jessica believes in non-violence we
can't wait to see how that makes her a
part of the team jessica has this
amazing alien ring it gives her the
ability to fly but it does a lot more
than that she can create anything that
she thinks of if you could create
anything from thin air you could
possibly defeat a villain without
violence - she is passionate about her
beliefs and she can be stubborn she is
one awesome character we really loved
the update to her character do you know
any other nonviolent superheroes that's
pretty unique do you have any friends
like Jessica tell us all about them in
the comment section Zatanna if you're
disappointed that some of your old
favorite two aren't in the new series we
have good news the new character is
awesome Dee's Satara
is the superhero Zatanna Zatanna is so
cool she has magical abilities she is
basically a witch she likes to perform
simple magic tricks but she can also
perform a really awesome spells to help
fight crime she's still getting the hang
of magic though sometimes her spells
backfire we bet that will be so funny
she can also fly she has a crystal ball
that helps her perform her magic she can
create magical portals - Zatanna is full
of confidence she likes to be the center
of attention but she isn't a snob she is
still an awesome friend to her team
superheroes Z is super stylish she
dresses in the cutest outfit and loves
makeup her hair is purple and sparkles
with magic she can be a little clueless
and sometimes vain Babs describes her as
charming though we just know that
Zatanna is going to steal the show it's
hard to be confident when you're a
teenager we wish we could be more like
Satana sometimes we are really excited
to have a magical superhero on the team
it makes up for the fact that Harley
Quinn poison ivy and katana are not
stars anymore we wonder if those three
are still going to be characters on the
show of course in the comics Harley
Quinn and poison ivy are villains do you
think they will be good or evil if they
are on the news show we would love to
see katana come back to in the original
series some characters didn't get
introduced until later seasons Green
Lantern wasn't on the show until season
four it's totally possible that we will
see some old familiar faces later on in
the show we are really excited about the
new DC superhero girls and we are
digging the new look
it's a Warner Brothers production and it
comes out this year we are anxiously
watching all the YouTube videos about
the new series we think it's going to be
epic what friends would be on your Super
Hero Squad let us know in the comments
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
to the things and keep up with all your
favorite shows
[Music]